Everyone says "Learning to learn" so that you can enter the best universities.
Success. But what kind of school is really important?
Let's take a look at the SAT scores of a regular school.
50% of students who successfully achieved a degree have achieved the best SAT scores.
Only 18% of the graduates are born to those with low SAT scores.
This is not surprising.
Now let's look at the situation at top universities, such as Harvard University.
At Harvard, those with low SAT scores are better than the best students in ordinary schools.
But their graduation rates are surprisingly similar to ordinary schools.
SAT high scores account for more than 50% of graduates.
Low score students account for about 15%.
What? This is the "big fish and small pond" effect.
It's very simple, we are just comparing with people around us, not people around the world.
Therefore, students in top schools are only compared to their peers.
If you are a middle and lower reaches student, then you can easily feel that you are not qualified.
Although compared to other people in the world, you are still a top student.
Which countries do you think have the highest suicide rate? Those developed countries that claim to be happy,
Such as Switzerland, Denmark, Canada
Or those who claim to be unhappy, such as Italy, Greece and Spain.
If you are very depressed and the people around you are equally unhappy, then you will feel that you are no different from others.
But if the people around you are more happy than you, then you become more depressed.
The same, if you are in a top school, although you are very smart, but you are ultimately unremarkable.
The idea that "I am very poor" will largely affect your confidence and motivation.
Need data proof? Among American science and engineering students,
50% of students will decline in the first or second year of college. Average grade of school SAT
For every 10 points dropped, students who earn a degree will increase by 2%. this means
If you don't choose the first-volunteer school, the probability of getting a degree is greatly increased.
Who is more successful in the "real world"? Someone about economists
The publications within 6 years after graduation were studied. research shows,
The 99th percentile top student is almost smarter than anyone else in the school.
They are the ones who publish the most articles in five schools.
But those 75th percentile students, although the top 1/4 of the students, basically did not publish any articles.
They have failed.
The same country, from the worst 30 schools, good students, published articles
More than the top 1/4 of the students in the school.
Obviously, the surrounding environment and peers have played a big role.
However, the above studies did not cover all aspects of studying top universities.
It is a glory to get a degree certificate from a top university.
It's also easy to find a job for you, but only if you graduate.
So when you apply for a school or when you are in a new school, you have to remember
Regardless of whether you are in the best or the worst school, there are many factors for success.
Believe in your abilities. Remember, good students in ordinary schools
Can be more important than school.
If you are worried that you are not doing your best at school, you can check it out.
Our original video, "The 9 Most Scientific Ways to Learn."
Welcome to subscribe to more weekly science videos!